hey guys welcome back to a brand new  video until they're going to be kind of  like talking about the new ornaments  that I guess dropped I guess no one  really there was no like trailer no  video I guess about the new ornaments  from about to show you that today before  we get into that quick 30 seconds of  your time there is a dead stream  tomorrow so I will be recapping all of  that unless you want to watch it  yourself but I will have all the stuff  on my channel tomorrow so Ben look out  for that and then in the comments below  I want you to tell me what your favorite  ornament was for all these characters  but I'll leave you guys to the ornaments  and peace out guys I will see you  tomorrow  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]